et vous venez de l'entente de la ferme
nouvelle me soulève bien des questions
il sufit beaucoup de réactions à
l'international pour tenter de décrypter
l'envers du décor nous sommes avec
mériadec raffray journaliste spécialiste
des questions de défense secrétaire
général de l'association des
journalistes de défense
bonsoir mais il ya des coeurs affres et
merci d'être avec nous à ses côtés
général françois chauvancy général de
brigade expert en géostratégie bonsoir à
vous également général alors on va
balayer à la question d'entrée de jeu
votre avis sur cette affaire la faire
navalni pour vous c'est quoi est ce que
les choses pourraient être finalement le
compliqué que ça en a l'air ou qu'on
veut bien nous les présentait on
commence par vous aimez riad est donc
raffray bon ça c'était fini écoutez moi
je constate que vous les choses sont
déjà très compliqué elles sont
bizarrement compliqué d'ailleurs enfin
bizarrement je m'explique navale lino
hitchock russie c'est un cocktail
détonnant et qui a explosé sur la scène
internationale à un moment intéressant
au moment où les tensions
internationales étaient forts sont
fortes au moment où les alliés se
dispute sur la scène internationale pour
plusieurs dossiers je pense tout de
suite au dossier me dit méditerranéen
mais n'est pas seulement au moment où
les deux où les partisans ont parlé les
les les membres de l'otan se disputent
voilà pour une première réaction
générale souvent si votre comparse
salaire me dire voilà que les choses
sont peut-être moins simple que ça en a
l'air qui a en tout cas un contexte de
dossiers en cours et que cette affaire
est évidemment allé à des répercussions
vous votre avis mais bon soir d'abord
oui moi je rejoindrai un petit peu ce
qui vient d'être dit par à mériadeck
avec peut-être en dissociant peut-être
deux affaires je dirais les deux à féron
je parle la première est une affaire
d'empoisonnement qui est une réalité
donc il faut une explication soient les
démentis soit elle est validée par une
enquête
alors aujourd'hui on voit bien que d'un
côté on dit qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'empoisonnement de côté on dit qu'on a
eu déjà si on régler ce problème là ça
faciliterait les choses ça c'est le
premier point la deuxième affaire c'est
en fait l'exploitation de cette affaire
dont provient des bocaux viens d'évoquer
c'est un cocktail entre le poison la
russie un opposant oui il ya une
instrumentalisation de cette affaire
mais il n'y aurait pas d'
instrumentalisation
si les réponses claires était donné sur
la tentative d'assassinât ou peut-être
simplement un accident mais je ne suis
pas certain que ce vraiment un accident
et voulait dire en général des deux
côtés les questions ne sont pas données
parce qu'elles ne le sont pas plus du
côté de l'allemagne on attend souvent
c'est cette croix 20 d'empoisonnement à
tout à fait je suis d'accord avec vous
il faut de la clarté la transparence
pour éviter une aggravation de la
situation
donc je crois qu'on est dans une
situation où personne ne veut assumer
des responsabilités
il ya des accusations je pense que
peut-être que quelqu'un est à deux
doigts qu'on la responsabilité de dire
de donner ce qu'il faut l'allemagne si
elle accuse elle doit apporter des
preuves
l'épreuve est importé à la russie et
d'un autre côté ce que moi je n'ai pas
vu pour l'instant depuis plusieurs
semaines sk une enquête en russie sur
cette affaire et je crois que déjà si
l'aspect judiciaire et non pas politique
était réglé peut-être qu'ils auraient
une moindre affaire politique mairie
avec un drap frères pourquoi ce aussi
compliqué dans ce type d'affaires à
chaque fois de prouver
voilà ce qu'on avance que ce soit du
côté russe comme du côté allemand
écoutez il ya 2 il ya deux choses il ya
d'abord premièrement le profil de
l'accusé ou de la victime ça dépend de
quel côté on se place qui est lui-même
troubles a présenté comme à nos pays a
opposé opposants politiques à poutine
qui fait 3 % dans les intentions de vote
en 2018 dans la présidentielle de 2018
c'est un tout petit opposants il est on
le sait bloqueurs lobbystes affairiste
il a été condamné dans de multiples
affaires et en particulier dans une
affaire d'extorsion de fonds de la
société yves rocher en russie donc c'est
un c'est un garçon qui est à la fois une
aura rien passé un passif
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il est il est
avéré également qu'il a des liens avec
les états unis il est passé par yale
tout ça ajoute au trouble ensuite il ya
la partie politique politicienne le
berlin et moscou se renvoie la charge de
la preuve comme on dit c'est ce que
vient de dire les général et à ce petit
jeu là évidemment impossible de
distinguer qui a tort qui a raison on se
retrouve dans le même schéma que la
sphère skripal
et puis comme j'étais tout à l'heure on
y ajoute la sphère du de ce fameux
poison nos vies chuck un mot choc
justement qui tout de suite dramatise l
affaire et qui est lui aussi est un
sujet en soi ultra complexes que seule
maîtrise à peu près les spécialistes moi
ce que je reproche que je retiens de
cette affaire c'est que cette bombe
explose à un moment crucial sur le
continent tout d'abord elle mais
l'allemagne face à ses propres
contradictions dans la sphère du gaz
nord stream une partie du monde des
affaires et des institutions donc porte
ce dossier une autre très atlantiste et
très pro otani à l'américaine et contre
celle ci évidemment sur la même longueur
d'onde que les états unis autour de
l'allemagne il ya un certain nombre de
pays qui sont très anti russe et qui eux
ne veulent absolument pas du gazoduc non
pas parce qu'ils sont anti russe
finalement mais parce qu'il ne
toucherait plus les subsides qu'ils
touchent grâce aux gazoducs terrestres
qui approvisionne l'europe voilà c'est
du côté du continent on voit aussi que
cette affaire explose au moment où la
campagne américaine reprend d'ailleurs
je note que peut être un beau passage a
dit qu'on n'avait pas encore des preuves
d'un empoisonnement donc il est assez
prudent je trinque on attend de voir
quelle sera la réaction de maiden et
enfin et surtout et enfin alors la
grande-bretagne comme d'habitude est
très en pointe dans l'offensive anti
anti russe c'est une tradition chez les
britanniques
et qu'est ce qui se passe en france on
voit et madame la crau qui est assez
gêné finalement aux entournures
moi je note si on prend un peu de recul
que le président m'a qu'on devait doit
se rendre à moscou dans les jours les
semaines qui viennent
la date bizarrement on n'a toujours pas
été officialisée le voyage va t-il se
dérouler ci se déroule ce des rades de
relative dans quelles conditions
là aussi cela pose question sur le
positionnement en fait de la france
vis-à-vis de la russie et vis-à-vis de
ses partenaires et enfin je le disais
tout à l'heure
cette affaire sem ou en tout cas
alimente la zizanie qui existe déjà dans
le la maison otanienne je vais vous
donner un exemple de cette izany qui est
aujourd'hui sur la place publique en
juin mi juin dernier la france a eu un
différend naval avec la turquie
le ministre de la défense français à a
demandé officiellement une enquête à
l'otan et celle ci s'est empressé de la
de mètres c'est le résultat sous le
boisseau
on sait que la turquie est un allié très
proche de washington et on sait
également que l'allemagne est un allié
politique de la turquie
voyez encore une nouvelle affaire qui
porte un fer dans le positionnement des
occidentaux vis-à-vis de la russie en
tout cas meriva qu'après vous avez
évoqué ce projet un hors stream deux
incertains la terre aux connexions
gazier entre la russie et l'allemagne
nous avait d'ailleurs évoqué les états
unis après que berlin menacer de stopper
ce projet je me propose précisément
d'écouté donald trump avant de faire
réagir le général show danse et bien je
soutiens ça j'ai été le premier à en
parler vous n'avez jamais entendu parler
de nord stream 2 avant l'arrivée de
trump
quand je suis arrivé j'ai dit attendez
une minute on protège l'allemagne de la
russie n'est ce pas général achevant si
vous partagez vous cette hypothèse ce
gazoduc qui serait peut-être aussi l'un
des enjeux en tout cas voilà qui tombe à
pic dans cette affaire une avanie ou ça
vous paraît alambiqué comme comme
scénario ça me semble à la fois on
alambiquée mais aussi plausible
aujourd'hui nous sommes effectivement
dans la guerre du gaz entre la russie
l'allemagne oublions pas que l'allemagne
est dépendante de la russie pour le gaz
la méditerranée dont on vient de parler
ma mère dekra ferait effectivement la
turquie qui veut investir la
méditerranée internationale a pour
mettre la main sur les gisements de gaz
on parle aussi au niveau de l'union
européenne de ce gazoduc qui viendraient
justement de ces champs gazier vers
l'europe pour réduire la dépendance
européenne du gaz russe et puis
effectivement trump qui par son gaz de
schiste souhaiterait le vendre à
l'europe
bon voilà nous sommes la guerre du gaz
alors maintenant nous sommes bien dans
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure dans
l'instrumentalisation une
instrumentalisation d'un fait divers
j'en resterai là je dirais pas un fait
politique un fait divers qui sert à de
multiples acteurs et effectivement la
complexité est très difficile à démêler
eux qui a le meilleur intérêt à ce que
cette crise perdure que ce soit l'otan
je suis pas certain je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord là avec mériadec raffray
sur la place de l'otan sur son
positionnement
oui je suis d'accord sur le point
qu'elle n'a pas soutenu la france ça
c'est une réalité mais bon à la limite
on a toutes les organisations
internationales que l'on mérite
les organismes internationales ne sont
pas toujours est loin d'être capable de
gérer des affaires nationales et des
intérêts nationaux donc une méfiance
effectivement mais que ce soit
directement liée à l affaire dont nous
parlons je n'en suis pas sûr maintenant
il ya un problème de dépendance du gaz
ces deux réalités et avec différents
acteurs la complexité je suis un cas pas
aujourd'hui de vous dire qui est le réel
coupables réels acteurs derrière qu'il
tire les ficelles c'est un ensemble
maintenant il faut garder raison et puis
finement pendant un peu de recul un peu
de calme et voir un petit peu dans le
temps comment les choses vont se
dérouler une chose est sûre c'est qu'on
l'a dit tout à l'heure à la france
reporte une réunion ministérielle franco
russe a des conséquences diplomatiques
alors qu'on sait que la russie et la
france
leur relation en tout cas se réchauffe
et berlin qui voit là parle d'arrêter ce
projet est ce qu'on peut imaginer que
les états unis joue un petit rôle là
dedans c'est rapidement s'il vous plaît
mériadec raffray
moi ce que je constate en tout cas c'est
que si la france a reporté une réunion
ministérielle là on est je dirais dans
le dans la posture officielle est ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que la russie va
sans doute très prochainement jouer un
rôle fondamental
jouer à nouveau un rôle fondamental en
méditerranée orientale cette fois en se
posant en en conciliateur entre les
grecs et les turcs dont on voit que de
toute façon la russie qu'elle soit
coupable ou victime dans cette affaire
va jouer dé facto un rôle important et
majeur dans les principaux dossiers de
tensions internationales actuelles
c'était hier plutôt proche orient c'est
aujourd'hui en méditerranée orientale où
le général chauve ans il a rappelé elle
surveille aussi les manoeuvres autour
des pays qui veulent mettre la main sur
les réserves de gaz découvertes au sud
au large de l'est de la chine qui je le
rappelle ont l'équivalent pratiquement
l'équivalent du gisement actu en mer du
nord
donc de toute façon et ce n'est pas le
cas des etats-unis aujourd'hui de toute
façon dans les semaines qui viennent la
russie sera un des maîtres du jeu du
tapis méditerranéen pendant que les
etats unis eux sont tourner d'abord vers
leurs crises sanitaires et ensuite dans
leurs querelles politiques dont ils le
11e on voit du mal à sortir
merci en tout cas à tous les deux nous
avoir apporté votre point de vue
mériadec raffray journalistes
spécialisés questions de défense
secrétaire général de l'association des
journalistes de défense et le général
françois chauvancy général de brigade
expert en géostratégie
merci à vous deux